qui l'eût dit ouais servait tellement
boniche castaldi bout chez les hommes
sachez le ce et 38% sont là à rechercher
une femme cultivée 42% sont d'abord à
rechercher une femme qui fait très bien
l'amour est ensuite viennent la beauté
12% et là mais chut chut % c'est quoi
vous alors présents parfois c'est
l'humour le mot les mains les mains très
important mais oui mais il n'y a pas les
moyens
alors là seulement voilà non non non je
dirais à cultiver
c'est la première à moore est très belle
donc cultiver en multi caméras le mythe
où vous allez vous dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
2 3 allez stop
alala même connu une femme était assez
joli mais tellement te bécaud c'était un
très bel été animatrice
non c'est un poète parce qu'une fois
qu'on a fait l'amour qu'est ce que ça
vous prêts on est très bien on appelle
un ballon d'or
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
kristen stade tout cas de kader attou
gagnent la finale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mathieu est ce que vous recherchez vous
chez votre cours et puis a pas la langue
de bois et tout un taille du sexe de
taille des portefeuilles poids taille de
la voiture il faut pas qu'ils aient un
sexe trop go et une boîte auto piétinons
ça rentre mais quand j'ai vu arriver un
range rover j'ai tout de suite su que
nous deux ça vibre aux bagnoles petit
peu par un soir c'est le bordel faisait
dumas yves à coup vous êtes puissante
sur un vrai clavier suivi j'ai alors
mais j'ai gardé les confitures c'est
d'ailleurs bien sûr bonsoir à tous
châteauroux prévient jean pierre
foucault je fais quoi
la nuit bonsoir alors les français vous
regarde
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi
j'ai ouais je sais les débits d'eau je
cache pas la présente émission c'est un
petit a dit sur son écharpe c'est un
petit peu comme vous allez bouche eric
escande à bombay vous allez bien ouais
[Rires]
j'ai l'impression d'être rappelé pour
descendre dit n'étaient pas en train de
divorcer
son départ est une bonne note